deep in the jungle
archaeologists are using choppers armed
with x-ray lidar cameras to study the
mysterious ancient ruins of Angkor they
hope to find out why the city is here
and why it was abandoned what they see
shocks them a truly gigantic mega city
hidden from view covering hundreds of
square miles this isn't just scattered
temples in fact there were thousands of
households and this whole thing
stretched out for hundreds of miles a
lost world
an ancient megalopolis on par with
sprawling modern cities we knew the city
was big but we didn't realize how big it
was this discovery isn't just big it
rewrites the history books of human
civilization
the x-ray eyes in the sky reveal a city
and civilization more advanced and
sophisticated than archaeologists ever
imagined but the images also leave them
baffled why was this mega city eaten by
the jungle its buildings strangled by
the trees three-quarters of a million
people that lived here in the Angkor
area and they're all gone what caused a
city this size to be abandoned so
quickly investigators study the lidar
images for clues they reveal a grid of
lines running across the entire city
analysis suggests they are the remnants
of a highly advanced water system it's a
network of water channels that form the
lifeblood of the city water is the key
to life and what what kind of
civilization were able to do is harness
water in all sorts of ways to think that
this complex engineering feat was
achieved over 600 years ago really shows
how complex the society was the lidar
images reveal at last the incredible
story of how this remarkable jungle city
was created
a water engineering system of such
sophistication it would have called for
techniques like those used today in the
Dutch Netherlands
[Music]
incredibly that's how this jungle city
managed to thrive but did the water
channels that brought life also bring
death